On this mountainous hillside in eastern
Java, I'm surrounded by hundreds, if not
thousands of coffee plants.
Coffee has been associated with
Indonesian history and economics for a
long time.
Yet there's a crisis brewing here.
Environmental change is decreasing the
crop and diluting the coffee.
And young Javanese would rather go to
college in big cities than work the land
as their forebears have java without its
namesake drink.
It's not out of the question.
There aren't easy solutions.
Farms could move to higher and cooler
ground, but that land has to be bought.
You can't just march into it.
There's a role for science here.
Let's try to develop more climate
resistant strains of coffee.
Given the popularity of drink at the
start of many people's day, why not
develop a reserve of beans equivalent to
the Strategic Petroleum Reserve in the
US or an IMF of caffeine?
You don't want top decision makers to be
without their morning fix for too long.